hallo leute seit einer woche sind wir
auf tour in deutschland und wir haben
die gelegenheit genutzt um die leute in
unterschiedlichen regionen in
deutschland zu fragen wie sie sich
begrüßen und verabschieden
hier seht ihr das resultat wie begrüßt
man sich in hamburg 999 wie begrüßen sie
sich in varel ja normalerweise man ganz
einfach mein abgeleitet von schönen tag
nun darf aber morgens mittags abends
nachts 9
woher kommen sie aus köln oder in der
nähe von köln und sie aus niederkassel
bei köln
wie begrüßt man sich dort hallo hallo
hallo hallo guten tag
es kommt drauf an wie man trifft ja ein
freund natürlich mit halo oder wenn man
bekannten sieht einen anderen menschen
die man nicht so gut mit dem man nicht
so befreundet ist dann sagt man guten
tag guten tag guten hallo hallo mein
schatz guten tag wie begrüßt man sich in
leipzig oder in sachsen mit hallo hallo
oder dach oder deutschen taschen
hallo oder guten tag oder hey ich auch
oft was geht was geht ist slang sprache
und heißt soviel wie wie geht es dir
manchmal sagt man ist auch als begrüßung
wie begrüßt ihr euch in baden
württemberg oder beziehungsweise in
heidelberg chris gott vielleicht in
baden württemberg in heidelberg hallo er
sei doch ziemlich international und
hochdeutsch doch eher grüß gott wie
begrüßt man sich in baden württemberg
auch mit hallo ganz normal oder guten
tag
dalli dalli hat hallo hallo hallo
woher kommt ihr aus freiburg wie begrüßt
man sich hier
hallo hey es ist glaube ich immer ein
bisschen unterschiedlich vom
freundeskreis zu freundeskreis hallo
woher kommst du aus mainburg im
niederbayern
wie begrüßt man sich in bayern mit
servus oder grüß gott servus servus wie
begrüßt man sich in bayern
servus servus servus servus museums und
wenn man wenn man sich verabschieden
es ist also beides so sie haben selber
servus
woher kommt ihr ich komme aus regensburg
und du ich komme ursprünglich aus der
nähe von wiesbaden wie begrüßt man sich
in regensburg servus sogar oma diri habe
die ehre
hb wäre bei uns eigentlich einfach nur
hallo und tschüss und schießt okay sagt
man ja noch gut wie zur begrüßung wie
begrüßt man sich in hessen
hallo nichts glaube ich nichts
außergewöhnliches hallo
wie begrüßt man sich in brandenburg man
sagt einfach pro tag oder hallo in
brandenburg gesang hallo zueinander wenn
man sich begegnet und er ist eigentlich
so das übliche wie verabschiedet man
sich auf fränkisch hd und wie begrüßt
man sich grüß gott servus es ist
unterschiedlich die älteren sagen grüß
gott
die jungen mehr servus hallo wie
verabschiedet man sich in thüringen auf
wiedersehen mit einem kleinbus auf
wiedersehen wie verabschiedet man sich
auf wiedersehen unterschied ich glaube
ich sag mal einfach tschüss oder oder
was man überall sonst auch sagt muss gut
macht's gut macht's ab
auf wiedersehen oder chips je nachdem
wie gut die leute kennst oder tschüss
bis bald und vierte weiß ja was
das heißt das ja auch viele sehen
piatti hd oder manchmal schon ein schuss
oder ag ist ein dialekt
ciao ciao und wie verabschiedet man sich
dagegen das servus oder hobby der habe
die erde
servus selber habe die ehre geht auch
noch dieses jahr was gibt es noch was
anderes für als aussah als airbus für
die verabschiede ich wüsste jetzt nix
museumsinsel oder zur sorge ist wünschst
du es wurde also quasi uns einfach dass
mit dieser dazu sagt wie verabschiedet
man sich auf fränkisch hd und wie
verabschieden sie sich in hamburg dass
da etwas besonderes tschüss mach's gut
so würde ich es machen nun das war unser
video zum thema begrüßungen und
verabschiedungen und wenn euch das video
gefallen hat dann würden wir uns sehr
über eure unterstützung freuen
wie ihr vielleicht wisst finanziert sich
unser projekt zum großteil durch spenden
und wir würden uns sehr freuen wenn ihr
uns helft auch weiterhin solche videos
zu produzieren
das könnt ihr zb als mitglied von easy
german machen das unterstützt sie uns
mit einem dollar pro woche und bekommt
auch etwas zurück nämlich übungen und
vokabel listen und ihr könnt uns
natürlich auch einfach einmalig
unterstützen die links findet ihr hier
und hier unten und wir bedanken uns
schon mal für euch danke fürs zu sehen
und bis zur nächsten woche
wie begrüßt man sich in nordrhein
westfalen bei schätzungen und die
verabschiedet man sich schon schätzelein